cyril robichez vous aimez venir souvent
ici pourquoi la vôtre choses à se dire
que c'est un deal world un pays
impossible me suis levé non non j'ai pas
par elles n'ont venir du maroc et non
sur les gens rien on n'a jamais dit du
mal des roubaisiens mais tu dois avouer
tout le monde je fais pas des gens qui
disent ils mais après j'ai des maîtres
et ben écoute j'ai jamais changé j'ai 65
ans maintenant suis venue au monde d'un
sida cette rue même et ma mère aussi la
langue maternelle et je viens de perdre
un moment elle avoue 87 ans et elle
était venue au monde d'harry princesse
est ce qu'on y lit mieux maintenant on y
vivait mieux avant que ce que te veux
qu'on pouvait qu on pouvait espérer nous
se tonde que ce qu'on peut on peut voir
il n'y a même pas de comparaison il n'y
a pas eu aucun de comparaison qu'on peut
penser au temps où on en est aux jeunes
est maintenant temps de détente jeunesse
de ce qui pouvait inventer ta vie tu
pouvais choisir ton métier que tu
pouvais faire ce que tu voulais ah non
non c'était souvent que c'est ça mon
dieu s'il pop - il n'y a pas de problème
puisque j'étais déjà mutilé de la guerre
de 14 le moment alors dit vas y aille en
enfer avec jambes deux mois il fera
qu'en donniez un
pied qui est un quartier de commerçants
c'est aussi un quartier ou deux par
tradition a toujours un petit peu fait
la fête en jeu tous rempli de café à
monsieur u6 et café en avons tous peur
tout comme yavo pas d'autres
distractions que natal café de chanter
un petit morceau chez laval vie lilloise
un champ non jouer
jouer bon tous les hommes les hommes les
plus âgés autant peu au caire mais quand
il ya il vole sous éléphants mais venez
noix de ses recherchés par exemple moi
je vais faire des pommes je vais parler
pour ma famille ah on allait rechercher
mon père lorsqu'un fait ma mère avec
avec les enfants on y voit un petit
canon comme ça tous ensemble et puis
après on dit souvent qu est ce qu a
beaucoup de bière mais alors je t'offre
véritablement d'alban bière parce qu'on
n'est pas loin de basri ouais on a rangé
pas quand vous travaillez d'avoir une
visite comme cela qui vient d'en garder
un petit peu au nom j'avance à quoi
mieux on a travaillé plus rapide quand
on a quand même at on expliqué de petits
trucs qu'on a fait un mal fou ici on est
accueilli veulent pas tant il dit rien
c'est bien mon quant à j ai toujours été
on est si on a besoin monsieur essentiel
noah aussi tombe et pas voué à un
malheureux
2g sakai petit quinquin chez soleil et
je vais vous dire aussi que simmons
poids nous chez notre vedette n'y a rien
qui en plaçant simmons petit quinquin en
1972 est toujours vivant je crois qu'il
est perpétuellement tokyo à des lillois
le petit caca arrivant dans le coeur des
lillois est un curieux c'est une chanson
comme chante porte et aussitôt que les
lillois se trouvant en compagnie sous un
prétexte quelconque une noce une fête où
n'importe immédiatement le kühler
de vielles petit quelqu'un quelle est sa
signification
le pic a qu'un c'est une chanson dormoy
recettes énergétiques berceuses et
quelqu'un c'est ce qui vous intéresse
peut-être quelqu'un c'est une altération
de du flamand quine de kid veut dire le
petit le petit petit petit petit c'est
l'enfance et le caca la chose la plus
extraordinaire c'est que cette chanson
une berceuse devient un hymne régionales
alors que ça ne se passe pas du tout le
mouvement ne se prête pas aux marchés
aux choses al kheir mais c'est parce que
je crois que tous les lillois ont été
bercés par cet art cette chanson et par
leurs ventes alors je crois que c'est le
souvenir de moments qui restent fidèles
au coeur des lillois qui sont tous peut
même des ptic a qu'un
ça s'est étendu à tous les départements
du nord du pas de calais de la somme de
l'aisne même on chante même à saint
quentin le p'tit quinquin et c'est à
juste titre qu il appelait la
marseillaise devises
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
même pas
une embellie thébaux là dessus ouais ben
schéma gagné 10,5 au wef est vachement
que les boys au fouet non mais cela vaut
parmi ceux-là bombe armée belge vanhool
délicat c'est annoncé mardi vers syrte
est peut-être mais gallas notamment aux
deux fois 24 ans
s'était dit cassé shawey alors
145 kg d'amitié
et 290 libre de sympathie ah oui à la
fois que 48 ans à main camarades arthur
sig et bill tchato grains puis dans une
autre et sérieux mettez maigrir nobody
145 kg un petit peu quand même que quand
il vient tout pâle na nana na na donc
je me suis affiché comme deezer je me
suis dégonflé mais c'est tout dit map
pack laisser aller avec une femme qui
m'a dit ça parce que je sais que ça fait
bientôt 38 ans de se marier 38 ans 38 le
ménage mon école serait alors elle m'a
chanté à la façon des sables où elle ma
santé toutes les salles et à le redire
quand je t'ai connu et aux costauds de
photos 72 kg bien bâti et bien élancé à
vous plaisir par métier non dit casse
toi avec ta doublé de fait 145 passé de
kroxxu pas exagéré de thé salaire tout
est sale et sa voix cat et un grand coup
pont je t'avoue fabio pantalon et black
hastert populeux m il manque au moins 20
centimètres gelé dans les elfes qui doit
zine n'y est élégant siens dalfin elle
ce n'est fait ajoute prix s'est
faite le soleil était sale et de ce
qu'il nomme quinzaine comme seule la
façade ou même les quartz et et doit se
terminer à la façon d'un sauna vous
embrasse qu'elle me dit puis après tout
ce point de notre faute on va au point
s'occuper des autres de ses mabuilu
convient mieux s'occuper rien que de
nous deux ma tante huit ans qu'on est
marié et soit pas vraiment bon souper
fait bien que ne soient pas oubliées
[Musique]